my biggest issue in politics would be
climate change and how it will affect
our futures education housing youth
involvement in politics migrant rights
climate action and the issue that
matters most to us is freedom of
movement between north and south of
ireland yeah just being able to move
across border without any issues
a prospering job market our biggest
political issue is the decriminalisation
of cannabis
our biggest issue in regards to m
politics is women's rights in regards to
abortion and sexual assault
[Music]
so what really matters to this
generation of voters across the island
of ireland
brexit the prospect for irish unity
climate change
are something completely different
we've come to the good summit at trinity
college to let them put their questions
to some of the decision makers
the sinn fein leader mary lou mcdonald
finigale td neil richmond and joining us
from westminster the dup leader sir
jeffrey donaldson i get to talk to these
people
fairly regularly but this is your
opportunity
my question is for jeffrey though
i'm a 26 year old unist from northern
ireland
and our greatest concern as our
generation
is at this moment time
is not our identity always to or our
tradition to the united kingdom it is
for our opportunities
is it not a social responsibility to
make sure that it is something to guide
the opportunities and actually stay and
work for
the young people in northern ireland and
with the irish government to create
those cross-border opportunities
i accept entirely your point that what
really matters to young people and to
their families as well is that they've a
decent future i wouldn't be in politics
if i didn't want to achieve those things
and it's not just the irish government
bear in mind that many of the
opportunities for our young people flew
from being in the united kingdom
and
therefore it means working with our
government at westminster as well
but i'm more than happy to
work with the irish government on
matters that help to boost our economy
and enhance cooperation but as i've said
at the moment um some of those
opportunities at least are being
undermined by what is happening in
relation to the protocol and we can't
forget that the protocol the withdrawal
agreement and the trade and cooperation
agreement are a joint product of the eu
and the british government no one has
single
ownership of this plenty of people have
ownership over brexit and i'm certainly
not one of them but i think what you had
was the european commission taking a
very reasonable stance of going to
actually talk and engage and listen to
the business people the political
leaders and the community leaders in
northern ireland to say well how is this
impacting you how can we make it work
better can't make it work perfectly
because brexit is ensuring that
nothing's working perfectly and we just
have to look at the petrol four courts
or rivers in england to see that
brexit's having a pretty bad impact over
there
my question is for marilyn
as you said you see the way forward is
for united ireland but has there
actually been thought into what a united
ireland would look like is there a plan
in place when i'm asked generally about
uh irish unity i get asked the following
what about the anthem
what about the flag
what about you know um a public holiday
for the 12th of july which i can i i
think is a good idea so
but we get into all of that
i respectfully suggest that's the wrong
place to start in my head where i would
start is with our health service
so what i think needs to happen megan is
not to rush i'm not saying let's gallop
to the polls next week and have the
referendum that clearly would be you
know farcical but what i am saying is
let's not lose time now
to start planning and discussing the
practical bread and butter issues that
matter
um do you believe i suppose that issues
of identity
uh got in the way of
a unified response to covert uh
considering obviously that
like science doesn't care about your
identity and ireland is
um an epidural epidemiological unit it's
a single entity
um in that sense so do you believe that
that is the case
there were times when you know unionists
like me opted to take measures in
northern that were different from those
in great britain so for example i'm in
london at the moment
and it is not compulsory to wear
a phase covering here whereas that
remains the case in northern ireland in
many settings that wearing face
coverings is compulsory so it doesn't
follow that as a unionist i just adhere
to what is decided in london or cardiff
or in edinburgh
or indeed in dublin for that matter i
think we have to look as politicians at
the unique circumstances
of our own communities and and decide uh
on that basis and on a consensus basis
where possible how we deal with these
matters so i don't think that identity
whether you're british or irish was a
determining factor in how
we responded to the
pandemic what is the most extreme
measure the irish government is willing
to
put in to pretend prevent climate change
june this is our one planet this is
i'm 16 this is my future it's going to
be greatly affected by this how
how extreme is your actions going to be
yeah well obviously it's not one action
i think it's a combination of actions
and it's also
the reward as well so i think a lot of
people think well we need to ban this we
need to remove that and i fundamentally
agree agree so one of the obvious ones
is banning the tailpipe car so you won't
have be able to buy an unloaded a new
unleaded or diesel car by 2030 in the
states fairly serious but it's also
rewarding to making sure that we spread
out public transport to make sure that's
an option to provide more funding for
cycle lanes in in urban areas but also
to move our public transport and our
public utility fleet over to renewables
completely so that's why we see hydrogen
buses coming on stream in dublin i think
that's the key thing but it's also to
look for the penalties for those who are
breaking and the guidelines the
commercial polluters who want a better
word and i think if you look at all in a
combination we can get there and we also
need to know very strong about this we
don't need to think climate measures are
somehow always a punishment there can be
huge opportunity huge opportunity for
not only for people to have a better
lifestyle but also for people to make
money and may have a very good uh
occupation on the back of it as well
the truth is that in the absence of
alternatives in the absence of public
transport in the absence of retrofitting
things that actually reduce emissions
carbon taxes in and of themselves won't
change behavior they become a cash cow
for the state they become merely a
revenue raising
instrument and i think that has been a
real problem with the political
discourse around the climate
emergency you